well then you figure oh then they can
get under with no wall I have I have the
barbed wire under the earth they do
there are little children through the
hole that's how they did it their will
to survive it overcomes my boxing today
and today we have a special guest we've
got Roseann on the show my brother yeah
big time how are you doing I'm doing
great Mike how are you doing thank you
in there thank you yeah you do well so
your grandma's Estelle Parsons yep great
the greatest thank you and your mom's a
bee that I worked with when she had a
magazine for big sized women yes mom I
stole all the clothes hey that's what
you gotta [ __ ] report me so I liked her
a lot more too yeah nice to meet you
it's great to meet you this is something
no no no you know if that's me anything
your family you really you didn't know
then as the show unfolds we get to know
each other a little better yeah you know
I wouldn't told that first if I was you
yeah early on I'm Estelle Parsons
great-grandson well I come in here under
the guise of having played in the NFL so
everybody yeah what did you play cuz my
both my boys met you and they were all
freaked out and tell me about it
Oh what did you play I played offensive
line tackle and guard uh-huh I was about
I was 6 6 3:30 a few years ago when I
left the NFL you are in the NFL yeah I
played for the Jaguars and the Bears you
play for the Bears yes I never wow
that's awesome yeah
thank you yeah I know is a bummer they
lost to the Eagles oh did that happen I
didn't know but who just won somebody
big yeah
boy he's a good-looking man that Tom no
doubt no doubt he's done a lot with
those looks he's a good play is he cool
you met him Mike yeah of course Mike met
everybody yeah I know everybody put you
with him and my kids and everything
little picture with oh well Tom Brady is
saying that he got a picture with you
well we have a picture together yeah
Mike how do you stay so damn humble
you're my guru man hey listen when you
realize to be as though we're much
longer to live on this planet yeah I
think - yes absolutely
yeah what about your common sense that's
why I like you Mike because you've got a
lot of the same kind of common sense
like I have because of our upbringings
and stuff don't you think when you go
through trauma as a child it like gives
you some special gifts of you know I
already view inspiration you know in my
ticket situation of I came from a really
bad neighbor real great poverty great
violence and stuff and so I if the
things with fainted stuff III send in
the chief of a shame in a situation I
hated living like that either
we are disgusting me yeah they will
never do that again but then you got the
birds right the birds are what lifted
you out right get me out of trouble but
didn't you like watching birds I have a
total bird thing that I wanted to have
you have a couple of thousand pigeons
it's crazy in Vegas no I have them in
New York I bought them in the oh really
yeah I bet you know everyone their names
too I know and everyone who they are who
is your favorite do you have a favorite
no really definitely really am what
about funny ones they don't seem funny
in it it was really fighting me no
[ __ ] yeah they do that's it that's
their two things thank you
don't think the life of a bird they rose
in you can get as close to that mic as
is comfy just because it sounds better
the things of that shaper I don't like
rope I get it I understand I don't know
why it reminds number Twinkie and I want
to eat it I'm so hungry
who do you think's got the worst drug
blogs in the whole [ __ ] world no no I
can't say that because I'm and title and
vehicle some drugs gonna kill you yeah
they shoot yeah dude okay student pot
smokers hey where do Tara tell you down
in the Philippines yeah yeah that's
ridiculous that's like a gang war on the
federal tournament is ridiculous oh
that's horrible
and will you shop for a joint Oh
terrible is that you know sometimes when
I'm in these foreign country they
painted and I'm on the balcony in my
hotel you're this really funky sweet and
I'm smoking my joint I'm looking over
the city and I think I'm gonna kill I
can't die right now yes my life you
think of how many people have died when
I ran for president in 2012 you know on
the Peace and Freedom Party you ever
prevail
yeah way to stay on top of [ __ ] buddy
I thought you knew everything I did you
start listening to me at some point I
guess okay it was the biggest double
triple millionth
mine [ __ ] anyone could ever walk through
and still retain a soul it was like 20
mine [ __ ] all at once and there's just
a lot of hate you know people gotta let
go of their hate don't you think Mike
man there's so much hate um flu I used
to have that hate to now I had it and I
didn't even realize where I had why my
man well see how much your life and life
is agreed only for your life is my
agrees because you live like an ass but
we have to hate and all this energy with
you
yeah hate energy yeah a lot of people
that's their battery hate energy yeah
wears me down I usually like that too it
was it would you hand me one of those
J's oh I thought those are all mine
your well I guess I can share one but
only smoked that much okay okay I'll
just no I'm just a control freak do it
you need I just want to control
everybody that's cool well because I'm
so much smarter than everybody and I'm
glad I'm here on this show cuz I can
always talk free around you and that's
why I like you I love to have somebody
smarter than you no I don't want to
because I know it's true before I don't
want it be true but I read the Bible you
know and stuff comes out of the Bible
for me what do you think about that body
boy I think that's pretty cool like
really you do oh so used to fighting
with people who won't talk about it they
won't let me talk well it's all a lot of
hate and [ __ ] just get rid of it man you
know they got people fighting each other
while they're stealing their money and
it all goes to money and it's like some
intense news out there now saying
because I said this years ago Mike when
that hsbc bank hack happened I knew that
was I knew they were just caught you
know it's just not I'm not gonna go for
there I'm on this side and that party
and I'm against now it's time to unite
and put your best thing forward get into
a peaceful place where you really dare
to [ __ ] see the light that is coming
to expose darkness everywhere I said
this is my presidential thing in this
twenty twelve you know they got to give
us depth forgiveness they got to get rid
all the debt they can do it it's the
stroke of a pen don't make people be
slaves to this under this great burden
of of debt and I'm speaking to everybody
Republican what party Drennen that Iran
the peace between a party which was the
Black Panther Party of San Francisco
because I was very involved in those
kind of left-wing policy that's pretty
deep I know and they chose me as the and
they chose me as the candidate of the
black
caucus of the Green Party so tell me
about the black caucus oh I will
incredible people yeah but they're all
like kind of they're all wonderful
people I'm not gonna say a bad thing
about nobody but you know what the Bible
tells us that we got to be aware of
great teachers who teach bad things
there can be great teachers but what are
they teaching you and if they're not
teaching you to stop all your [ __ ]
fighting in your gang turf war it's
gonna don't amount nothing less or more
than that and start like doing [ __ ] the
way it should be done according to your
highest conscious point which connects
with the divinity of intelligence get
into the [ __ ] intelligence man wake
up my mother friends okay black people
got their [ __ ] together man either deal
with it what was it like with the caucus
the caucus was led by Cynthia McKinney
who was the previous candidate of the
Green Party and the Green Party went
through all this stuff with Cynthia like
inviting Ralph Nader to speak instead of
Cynthia at their convention which was
such a slap in the face to all the Black
Caucus and it just was going on and they
were just unconscious about the [ __ ]
they were dealing and I'm like why are
they so why did they not see the actual
people on the ground in front of their
face but they can't you know they're not
there's no money in that but anyway I do
believe in God and all that and I don't
care what anybody says about it did they
help you to caucus oh my god they were
my they were my dearest friends what
were your running points and the war on
drugs legalized audit the Federal
Reserve which I'm so happy to see
there's rumblings that our president
might be considering that there are
incredible papers you think so
oh I don't think any of them are
credible I think they're all
doling out like they took a great big
old thing like when you make pizza and
you roll it you know and then like you
cut it in quarters
Papa John's get this and Domino's gets
you know it's all just turf it's all
just about how to move product and the
bad thing about it is that the people
who move the product well they need to
be paid fairly and get a percentage of
the profits because losing the product
huh moving the product kings and [ __ ]
yeah of course it's always like our
royal masters what do you think like
that happen the Rockefellers the
Rothschilds what are they they don't
learn they work for kings the real work
for they work for the Kings the Masons
the skulls everybody works for the King
the king of King who's that you take a
look and tell me that God Jesus tell me
I don't know it's a human it's a human
who has a lot of power more power than
anybody else on this planet say a prayer
I'm gonna say a prayer for you that God
will give you the words and you'll know
yeah wasn't so bad you know my dog my
you know about Hannibal man come on
let's talk Hannibal he crossed out the
cutoff there was another panel around 2
to 15 to 10 BC yeah he cornered off the
the Romans and went over the Alps and
stuff which was the real elephants yeah
but which is a really horrible strategic
move yeah elephants have never seen
Nicole and Anthony did horrible in the
mountain to Tyson
yes he lost a lot of people just put the
heroic attempt they made in legendary
but it was a real guy and we were
talking about what must you think to
come to those conclusions I mean put
trying to put yourself in like this
great thinkers place it's really a fun
thing you know a lot of things you can
think of this you can think of Alexander
the Great Cooper in the world at 20
years old yeah yeah you know yeah yeah
right brother that's whoa that's mine Bo
and then imagine a drug those guys used
back then the crazed if different
praised if you smoked
yeah that Persian the Persian stuff any
of the toad are you talking about
Persian stuff yeah yeah the king of
kings yeah who knows but I think you
know I'm only talking on the human world
yeah yeah not God and all that we all
have our opinions on what that is you're
talking about the elite of the elite I'm
talking about the head honcho of all
head honchos right you had the big one
yeah you know who it is you don't want
no one to know who he is come he they do
they're gonna kill him probably well not
if he has a lot of walls oh I'm sure
that's why we don't know who he is I
don't know but I think I'm saying
where's the biggest walls the biggest
walls China yeah that one's a big-ass
wall I'd like to build a wall like that
around my farm to try and keep these
wild pigs out Mike you got to give me
advice there are these big old boars it
was my grandkids okay I'm taking out 30
a month how you getting over the shock
crazy I'm not killing nothing because
I'm opposed to that but you know that
Hawaiian people will they do depend on
that animal and they fatten him up real
nice they blow em up well they do what
they do in their tribal way I think that
I'm telling people hunting them and that
was the thing you should come in what
you should go hunting with Hawaiians no
I ain't killin animal oh no I know I
don't either but still they'd have to
like I get it when there's dire people
of the forest yeah you have to protect
yourself against them that's why yeah
I'm always armed
I'm eyes are out there yeah I'm sure
they have tusks they can get to us yeah
they're mean one time was as big as a
goddamn Volkswagen I believe it they get
really
and they're [ __ ] right on my porch
that's what I understand why don't they
know what gets them in trouble mean -
they don't give it down no they look at
you like you're beneath them and they
are smart I fenced it they got through
the fence you know what they did they
threw their kids through the fence
they're little tiny babies and then when
they grew up they had babies on my land
a populated out there they're overrun
and what do they want or what are they
eating are they're eating up all the
profits all your veggies and stuff yeah
and that's pissing me off because I'm
not there to learn to grow my own you
know stuff yeah and when they're eating
all my avocados which I'm depend on
animalic ADO's for my feeling better
yeah that's why I grew them and they're
over there eating them all I'd be pissed
and they all might papayas - every day
[ __ ] papaya every one of you know a
couple thousand trees that I put in
there with my own well [ __ ] hands
just devastate I'm at [ __ ] I feel
like I'm in a life-or-death struggle
between me and the pigs well ma I wonder
thought we'll build you wall then dig it
well then they can get under wood no
well I have but I have the barbed wire
under the earth and they threw their
little children through the hole that's
how they did it
yeah their will to survive it overcomes
mine I mean it's a car man it would be
like that they're well to [ __ ] survive
is overcoming my will to survive and I'm
not gonna die and I know something about
you I'm not gonna die out of this hell
being dumber a [ __ ] pig see it's a
karmic [ __ ] spiritual thing I'm doing
here
and how do you stay so calm these days I
don't know how to do this but tell me
about something
tell me well how was your first gig and
how did you get it - you remember your
first gig ever did hmm all right last
year a Christian gig what what how are
you defining the word get paid to work
love in the screen or something paid for
work on TV or anything it's a commercial
whatever oh yeah commercial well my
first commercial I went up on was in
Denver Colorado and you know it was just
a turf war there two eyes never with the
right guys that [ __ ] won that one I
was always with the one that got bought
by somebody else who didn't like me it
was like a big ol maze that I had to
think my way out of because like it's
weird when you start thinking of
yourself as a product you know that
that's weird I think of myself like that
when I used to be funny I'm proud I'm
inside don't think of your objectives
just get to the next level yeah right
but I'm not gonna kill them
I've decided spiritually I can't kill
them because I think that's the Dumber
thing to do because you know then you're
helping feed the whole story that you're
against them so I'm trying to re-educate
them and I got these two they were
really cute little babies so I put them
in with my sheep and my goats right so I
thought well do two wild pigs you think
there are the babies they broke through
the fence so they're cute and I'm like
you know I'm like this is your karmic
thing I'm like you're gonna make peace
amongst these here tribes right because
I saw that movie babe
yeah that movie changed my life it was
the greatest [ __ ] movie did you like
it
every moment I think if they're taking
my kids to see it - oh they'll love it
many years ago but give the Luther groan
there at that moment I thought the
sexist man who'd ever been on screen
James cam something Cromwell
yeah yeah thank you handsome dude great
face for the camera camera loves names
great actor I'm like old-time Hollywood
now the camera loves the kid you know
for sure the camera loves everybody
whose face is either really round or
long interesting and the biggest stars
have the long and round face with them
with the big jaw I'm a Jew and I just
want to say I I don't judge anyone by
anything except for their head shape
because that's what I've been taught you
want me to read your head I'll raise
your hand well you got a one of a kind
head yeah now I love the tattoo there
can I hear about the tattoo before I do
it I gotta hear why you put that on your
face okay cuz when you mix them to know
[Laughter]
tribal and came to we came to this and
what is the significance of the
Marschallin tribe you know I mean the
native of New Zealand knew the mother
Maori truly is a warrior yeah that's who
that was like the whole Moana movie did
you see mo wanna get your kids and watch
Moana yeah it's a mind-blowing movie for
kids they've got to go see it Moana is
this coming queen of this tribe
chieftain of this tribe and she s chief
tes and she has to go out and basically
figure out why death is kind of coming
to overtake her Island because there's
no more food coconuts returning to ash
it's so not about that but this is so
good in the male thing it's so great to
see how men think I'm fascinated books
find Maui who's the demigod to help her
get the heart of taffy tea to bring back
to her Island to restore life to it
that's that's good all that's good but
you know what to told your content is
good but your context is not you're
clear you're not clear on your context
before I did I just barely did cuz i was
saving that from my 60s because i knew
i'd go to wiped out so I never did none
of them so in my sixties in Hawaii I'm
like [ __ ] it I'm gonna take a mushroom I
get it hard to get though well someone
was kind enough to gift me with one at a
sacred ceremony in Hawaii that's cool I
would do much yeah really I had to go
out in the forest where there were no
humans because I have always carry my
machete with me when I go out in the
forest and you know if you watch my
stuff I record on my own YouTube channel
about me and my machete and how I you
know the power of the machete and you
know I went through all that and it's
really powerful
you can cut anything down it's cut down
like heavy-duty trees and little tiny
blades I've tried it on everything I
love my knife slices right through no
you got to have a stance it's not just
like you just don't go up like it no I
don't take off a piece of butter you
have to have a stance or yeah yeah all
right well then I took this drug called
the tone and it blew my mind man it
really took them to another planet yeah
I've really what planet
man it was a dimension I can't even
describe could you describe anything
about it it was like a quick rush it
happened real fast and I smoked boom
exploded on the place
you know you see the Aztec 13th in your
minds Russian real fast food is gonna
fast about it man [ __ ] you know
anybody's your mind moving chillin other
things go fast you think you're dying
can't breathe and then you wake up you
mean a panic mode
oh yes wake up happy oh you wake up
happy so let's I can reverse panic mode
yeah yeah don't know where you going oh
my god hey but were you connected to
anything
like a a spiritual source or anything
yes I believe them go through that
process I believed that I was gonna die
I couldn't breathe it was just um I was
just some beliefs and no more worries I
was just released nothing mattered
Monday I had no ego I was just dealing
with my mortality
that's a heavy duty [ __ ] thing I hate
that one I've had that a lot too well
sometimes well though do you think when
you have dark dreams that your days are
dark too after doing that taking a turn
I have things I don't really confront
dark nothing no darkness is gonna have
to confront me eventually that's gonna
be like for it oh yeah I wait for the
come I know it's gonna come I've been
sleeping better Mike I choose not to
sleep I always get up early and like to
watch television at 2:00 in the morning
or something yeah
and walk around and go on a treadmill
but I feel that it's all I'm really not
sleeping kind of person yeah I want to
sleep other thing it's awesome how much
do you sleep oh no four hours baby do
you take a nap
anything they have someone absolutely
the office during the day - yeah nap
time I love this play this in the best
German where you come here smoke you
fall asleep on the plane
I've been on those conversations it this
is great in life what made you want to
be a comedian well I thought if I could
make these [ __ ] laugh instead of
fight that by me six days somebody'd see
there was value in me making fun of them
no but doing it you know your time as a
kid I'm a teenager young woman you made
people laugh and somebody fail you're
funny
well I didn't know I was funny till they
were all laughing nice child I'll get it
but when they did laugh you know I knew
I was funny but when they didn't laugh
and I knew I was funny I was like [ __ ]
him I know I'm funny they keep on saying
I'm not funny but I'm real funny to me
Christ I crack myself and [ __ ]
quarters I love to laugh how do you get
on that stage doing you mean absolute
strangers laugh at you well I would
refer to think they're laughing with me
yeah yeah I always try to get him on my
side first I mean isn't that like with
your boxing you're gonna you got a lull
them into that first you know you got it
you've got to do like I was seeing what
you were saying when you were fighting
and that was the show you know what you
were doing and what you were saying and
you I mean you were noble are I'm
talking about you what make you gonna
stay that people who watch you because I
I was like I don't know I was like when
I was a kid god this is a hard question
to answer in English because their
English don't contain the right words at
times for me when do you like to attend
to me if you decide I want people to
look at me I just was being me I don't
know what they wanted but I did see that
if you did make them laugh they shut up
sometimes and you know start
being such [ __ ] grumpy [ __ ]
and hateful [ __ ]
so I'm out I just got tired of it so I
was like god you're gonna make them
laugh at themselves you don't just make
them laugh a lot of people can make you
laugh
you nobody's doing a fart joke as simple
as that you'll laugh laugh laugh but
there's something else you know it's
it's got to say the right [ __ ]
nobody's gonna think it's funny so
you've always got to shape your message
and your words and stuff and what you're
really trying to say so I said to myself
what would be the best thing I could do
that's what I'm gonna choose I don't
know people should get over their anger
now come on this is now we've all done
terrible things ok everybody sorry ok
let's start again and do something
better we have the capability to use our
technology to benefit humanity and I
think people are waking up to that but
they really got to investigate - what
does that come down to what does it
really mean I was in a big demo that a
lot of did I like 60 million bucks I
know you do how do you do that you have
a yard sale or what do you everybody had
two guards I believe I did it that's
happened that that's the first thing to
go all your possessions take that I have
to do jobs gigs gigs make deals with
them the government stuff so yeah mine
took me a long time to pay never [ __ ]
you I paid tax next year all right spin
and spin and spin [ __ ] you I really
didn't care you didn't care if you
pissed off the IRS oh no I was living
there
living life I was so attached I was so
uh I was out there big thing I never
wanted to piss off the IRS IRS is the
biggest form of extortion in history of
government well that's what Trump says
I mean it's a mess morning one of those
guys I don't know if it's trumpet
somebody saying that imagine we live in
a socialist country no way no [ __ ]
way man not when you see what it leads
to
goodies yeah but there would still be
some ass I know
oh yeah you did oh good for him it looks
good on him hey was he saying that Rob
takes his his planning inspiration from
you Mike did you know that no I had no
idea he frequently quotes you he says
everybody has a plan until they get
punched in the mouth Trump says dude did
you really say that
we gotta get Trump in here no ask no I
want to ask you about that now wait a
minute what's it like to get punched in
the [ __ ] yeah really bad yeah that's
why everybody has a plan until you had
parts to the mouth he gets frustrated
when there is a plan but Mike you like
plans cause I know but guys you said I
said I don't have content to live I said
you know that's pretty cool what dude I
mean is the plan tell us your plan you
got one right well nothin fine at this
particular time though yeah my plans
really at the take over the cannabis
world okay but I mean what's it like to
be the the champ of the world being the
champ ooh
stress but you did yeah yeah but yeah my
hair used to fall I'll be so stressed
really yeah Wow champion being a
champion amazing driving that's - I took
anything too serious back then I throw
him now everything's happy it's loose
focus - [ __ ] serious how do I
remember I went to chill out please
remember we went to Versace yeah gather
with donkey yeah I certainly do I still
have those towels no problem what's it
like Mouse death I think there will give
this that was when I was in my belly
Jack mode
yeah but exactly what is your cell phone
- somebody changes in your life oh yeah
you know and trying to stay strong and
in the spiritual light of your beliefs
and not so out to things you don't
believe in because God what would that
be like horror I just can't do that
right yes it's horrible [ __ ] yeah you
know it's pure isolation cuz you're like
but then the good part is well you start
to think well how many other people can
I bring with me you know and then you
think well I'm gonna try to bring other
people along with me and I did that and
you know I did it so anyway I'm on doing
that yeah helper huh you're a helper I'm
a Jewish mother well now I'm a Jewish
grandmother I can't help myself I'm
gonna stick my nose everybody's [ __ ]
business and when I see they're doing
wrong why I'm gonna tell them they're
doing wrong I just want to say what's
the [ __ ] plan what's the common goal
you ever think about no I know you don't
anyways there is one loving happiness
drugs out there first in there we will
have a guard up to much
[ __ ] yeah truck you gotta have trust or
you can't get peace right exactly
Erlang or love or anything but in what
you've got to continually ask yourself
don't don't lose sight of the what the
what is really important what did you
guys think of this experience you had
this interview that's pretty cool we
just coming out of prison
I don't know was just um I was at my
house a pretty cool time I did some you
know I had my uh Tiger for a long time a
year and a half by now did you meet the
tiger I did meet the tiger that was
another turning point in my whole life
too cuz he's like here's Mike know it's
okay to meet the tiger he was talking to
the tiger about me oh I just was a
witness but he has passing something
back and forth there and I was just be
holding it and going well you know
that's a that's the process he goes
through but then he's like okay well
allow me to introduce you it was sort of
like I can't remember the roads but the
feelings like that telepathically or
whatever that's pretty awesome
and so well I went in there and I've
never before in my life ever dared touch
an animal I have had a horrendous fear
of you know ever touching animals why
well because I think right yeah I
thought now it's just logical you don't
want to go sticking your be all hands in
their business that's begging for a bite
yeah beggin for losing a finger no doubt
especially something like a tiger but if
they come to you and are prostate or
prostrate or whatever the [ __ ] word
is when they're submissive to you then
you can loud them in your space yeah but
then you're locked in being like
you know dominant bondage title
relationship yeah a BDSM relationship
and you don't uh oh you have a picture
of it oh my god I've made a video of it
yeah there you were oh my god I was like
oh my God look at him he's melting as
into one mind yeah this beautiful mouth
I did a drug for them what's the worst
one what about them psychiatrics
I know you did you went on psych yeah
Cody I did some serious hikes factors I
was in the psych ward a couple of times
too buzz yeah on what on psych meds yeah
yeah they really take the edge off don't
I get you really preferred you say why
was that place out that was there one
time you know how did I get there so
you're not that's not a detox a psych
ward oh hell no well you talks is nice
yeah yeah well number one to detach
those on this behind yeah well I was in
a state institution for almost one year
in Utah boy they lock people up a lot
all over this country and you know
what's your favorite movie movie
all-time rose and go
I think it's obvious I'm voting Lord and
mention it because it's alright it has
bad consequences
alright then then you're like forcing on
a period
lest language on me and I am like
certifiably insane and I don't buy any
of your opinions on sanity so I can't
even enter the conversation because I
don't buy it
I only want to do [ __ ] that benefits me
and that makes you like undesirable is
your favorite movie though I am I'm
afraid to say it was because I had such
bad karma
well that was I've had several and they
change top three oh my god the effort
Exorcist
definitely a lot only [ __ ] mind
during the x32 I ran out shrieking it's
a masterpiece it was a devil worship
movie I can do it
really yeah the underlying message or
just what it's about I mean you think
William Friedkin was like I can't
remember what movie we're talking yes
my experience of cult members and I
could easily be a member of a cult oh
yeah he's been and I think I'm bright
and smart and stuff like helium II dug
into that crap have you ever watched
that it was like an eight part show on
one of those networks I can't figure any
of those buttons out on my remote so but
I did see it it was about an actual
group that that guru in Washington or
something that went and bought it he
bought land and put a town on it huh
what did he do there yeah the Rajneesh
that was so good what movie are we
talking about wild wild country
excellent movie Mike you should remember
that movie who's in it wild wild country
huh it's about the Bhagwan this yeah
that's and it's a serious
series not a movie yes it really has a
shocking ending yeah what do you think
about the hippies in the 60s and it
shows the woman who was like he fought
the Bhagwan and she's less in
Switzerland under cover now she's like I
tried to teach the Bhagwan what it meant
to equality and he it was just a man it
was like and she's walking around in
Switzerland now yeah I so want to
interview her yeah god damn what a convo
yeah I mean she ran the whole operation
yes she she bust in the homeless I'm all
over the state attempted to kill those
guys came in and they poisoned her water
she said yeah there was a turf war who
are we as people man that we're thumb
you know we think we got it all together
then one day somebody come to me with a
flare and it's Kara Maddox and also me
following this girl henceforward is like
the Bible well we're tribal creatures
right you know and so well we're wired
friendly we're wired for tribal
community to be involved in that and I
think most people are looking for a
leader somebody to tell them what to do
and show them how to live so when
somebody comes into the picture and they
have a structure of how to find
happiness how to attain a relationship
with God how to feel good about yourself
people just fall in love with that you
know I understand it but I think that
people are smart yeah I do
definitely adaptable should Mike run for
president dude he'd win I know this guy
would win I don't know brother I'll help
you do it I'll be your campaign man you
want to though you wouldn't want to
no way Jose smoking so candidly smoking
in the Oval boot yeah well I I just wish
people could figure out some [ __ ] way
of hearing you know the other side and
and like you're solving a [ __ ]
problem rather than publicizing its
defeat that's difficult well I think you
know you hinted at it earlier Roseanne
what there's this light coming to shine
shine into the darkness you know of a
lot of places of our culture and I think
that just get ready yeah I got a
conspiracy for you come tell me so you
know this 10-year challenge that's going
on right now really don't there's this
10-year challenge and everybody is
posting pictures of them from 10 years
ago and then them from today and
apparently people are saying that
Facebook created this to gather more
data to facilitate their facial
recognition technology so how do you
keep facial recognition what a robot
world are you talking about what alien
language you've been infected by the
aliens Oh have you ever been abducted
and as hard as you tried
so I'm Facebook Mark Zuckerberg they had
to shut down this AI system that they
created beginning
a I started its own language and was
communicating yes yeah that the Facebook
it's like so 2001 a Space Odyssey it is
that's the other movie that really
[ __ ] me up well the first movie that
ever [ __ ] me up
of course oh my god was a was the Wizard
of Oz that's a [ __ ] and then uhm
Citizen Kane I was a girl awful well
those are gone
how the girl rode by the [ __ ]
ho-oh and the Godfather - that was
awesome - oh great ones Citizen Kane
really hit me hit me good - yeah
about William Randolph Hearst who
started [ __ ] cannabis propaganda oh I
forgot about that part yeah yeah because
he had all kinds of paper trees that he
was profiting off of and hemp was this
up-and-coming industrial crop that could
be used to make it well Trump just
legalized him my mom's awesome I was a
big deal
I mean maybe once in a while the guy
does something good yeah no doubt
I don't hate on nobody I never have I've
done things out of ignorance though but
everybody has yeah right you say the
wrong words and you don't even mean them
how they're saying you Madame and you
didn't mean them that way at all and
it's like huh
that's the lowest common denominator of
thought you could have conjured up to
interpretate my tweeting you just want
people to start getting along with each
other right mark they'll be nice thanks
Mike that's all I want to say come on
now you we can we can we can just agree
right now forget the past
right now let's agree let's do the right
thing to help each other and are in our
neighbors I agree I agree will then we
should do that no doubt mhm
what are you up to these days Roseanne
me sitting here with Mike against
I mean that [ __ ] is the greatest
thing that's ever happened it's the best
ah well thank you for coming
it's awesome
she got stolen the first time we met we
did you know I remember we did I knew
your memory be different oh no you
wouldn't smoke okay you did okay and I
did get it on film you owe me man
well when was that now you do back then
you might have been a little scout
how great is pause your part is the
greatest part I don't notice but smoking
the dictum huh it was so nice to talk to
you Mike thank you so much oh man thank
you for having me Hans it's my pleasure
thanks for the part
oh it's welcome it's healing ganja AIDS
it's a healing spiritual ganja okay it
has my rabbinical seal that was my
blessing for you Mike it has my
rabbinical seal yeah not sure there's
your blessing I told you get ready to
contain that but it has my my rabbinical
seal is on that like my trademark or
whatever the [ __ ] it is hook it up
whatever who is the most powerful person
on that planet
this is about information who who is the
most powerful powerful person person on
the planet on the planet
heavy dude ever been googled before it
says Vladimir Putin uh-huh
a lot of people would agree with that
why is that though does that say number
one is Putin see that's Forbes Forbes
that's not [ __ ] Forbes [ __ ] that was
like all right none of them are right I
told you that's all disinfo oh wait no
he's number two you know who's number
one who G Jinping of China general
secretary what do you think that's not
the guy well thank you guys for another
great episode of hotbox and Mike you're
the man thank you I appreciate you
brother and thank you thank you Roseanne
and we'll see you all next time we're
out of here
out of here
[Music]